hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday november 15th
what's going on how are you
you're probably thinking well jesus bill
you usually have a little more [__]
energy than that you usually have a
little more volume
you know
to watch i say stop [__] nitpicking
all right you ever think that maybe just
maybe i'm in a hotel room right now and
i can't scream [__] at the top of my
lungs
um
i am currently uh i am in milwaukee
wisconsin by the time you hear this i'll
be back though
um
one of my favorite cities and what
sucked was i
you know i just got here
landed
you know had to do two shows and then
went to the packers game and i didn't
get to do all the [__] that i wanted to
do but the good thing is i'm going to
get to oh i'm going to come back
and do it another time the next time i'm
going to bring my wife here
i love this [__] place but anyways i
had a great
great time out here man um
first things first i got to give a shout
out
to another uh
rapidly becoming one of my favorite
cities detroit michigan
um
i love that city i like all those
[__] places they call the rust belt
and all that [__] i like all of those
and just watching all of these cities
you know pittsburgh came back
cleveland came back and now you're
seeing detroit's heading in that
direction it's really cool thing to see
and uh we played the fox theater
absolutely legendary legendary place and
the sound i can't even tell you how
amazing the sound was
the crowds were amazing
and you know everybody's just psyched to
be out and i just felt in the best way
the crowd was like just egging me on
to be more of an idiot than i usually am
which is fun you know what i mean i had
a great time
sorry i'm reaching for something here i
don't want the [__] cord to fall here
um
and you know when the sound is what it
should be
you know that's when you can really you
know
take them on a ride because then you
don't have to feel like you just gotta
be up there like if you can't hear
yourself you think you gotta like they
then you think the crowd can't hear you
and then you after a while you realize
all right i'm blowing up my voice
they're laughing they can hear me so i
need to just
deal with the fact that i can't hear
myself and then there's nights like
in detroit at the fox theater where
you know what i mean it's like they
turned on the lightsaber
so now you can bring your voice down you
can take them on a little [__] weird
sinister thing or whatever and then
bring it back up and do the [__] joke or
whatever you take them on a [__] ride
so um
just absolutely absolutely incredible
incredible crowds
um i got a little bit detroit pizza i
went touristy you know next time i'll
dive a little deeper i went to buddies i
know it's a chain i know that oh would
you go to buddies dude you should have
gone to [__] mario
whatever
hey
i guess i'll just have to come back
again you know am i supposed to hit
every place at the same time
so uh went there at a great time um
nate bargatsi and mike vecchio were
playing the mgm so we got to hang out
you know
and um
just had a [__] blast hanging out
with them and i stayed in a really cool
hotel
and uh you know it's [__] hilarious
you know detroit throughout the years
it's just literally looked like
you know looks like the end of the world
you remember how [__] up it was when
people actually quarantined or supposed
to quarantine or whatever in the
beginning the pandemic and just cities
just look like ghost towns like that's
what this [__] looked
like that's like [__]
like zombies had come in and eaten
everybody and they had gone to bed until
night and you were just walking around
during the day like where the [__]
is everybody man it was a um
fascinating [__] place to be there's
been a few like that like cincinnati had
a little bit of that vibe i'm going back
i've been on the road forever guys i've
been doing this for like 30 years so
like it's sort of the
you know before computers and growing
weed started bringing some money you
know whatever the [__] happened
or you know
people from china and russia trying to
hide their money in glass towers over
here whatever happened i don't know what
but
um these places are starting to come
back which is which is great you know so
um
so this time i was there i was staying
in this the hotel
and uh
i [__] uh
you know i opened the curtain to see
what my view is and i'm looking across i
got there at night i took the red eye in
and there was just like a bunch of
lofts
with no curtains for whatever reason
just like wide open
i was i felt like uh jimmy stewart in
rear window and i'm just looking at
somebody sitting on a couch watching tv
there's another one there's a woman
sitting there on her computer i'm like
what the [__] like
i closed the curtain
and i was like all right this is the
beginning
when the city comes back you know the
soto sopas i always refer to that south
park now legendary episode for me
the one about gentrification everything
trying to bring white people back white
people love lofts
you know in south park you know you got
to get the whole foods
to validate yourself or whatever i don't
know they got something going on there
because there was just a bunch of
[__]
you know white people in these lofts and
it was still so new they didn't have
curtains i guess
i remember like like
i was there for two days
and at some point during the second day
i opened up the curtain to get some
light in there because i keep [__]
losing my mask right
where did i put it in my jacket pocket
is it [__] over here you know it's my
it's my new cell phone the new thing i'm
trying to search for
so i open it up
and who doesn't i mean i'm white i love
a loft
i don't know why i'm making it racial
like only white people like lofts but i
just remember always throughout all
these movies that i watch i'll be back
to like kevin bacon and quicksilver
anytime you lived in a city they always
had these giant [__] lofts and
they're riding bicycles around them and
everybody looked like they were
struggling but you knew they had money
you know
um
sort of like uh
poverty chic sort of look and now of
course those things are you know i guess
artists used to stay in them down in
soho started down there in new york i
think and now they're worth like a
zillion bucks i don't know what happened
so anyway
so i was gonna like window shop i
figured it was during the day no one was
gonna be home and there was like a glare
on my window or another person's window
and i was looking down this apartment
and i was like
it kind of looks like a
woman's face
i kind of moved a little bit i realized
it was just a woman looking right back
up at me and i was looking like right
back down here it was one of the
freakiest [__] i felt like i was in
the ring or something
i just shut the curtain i was just like
you know nowadays i'm like oh [__] is
she gonna feel not safe is she gonna
like report me and stuff it was like i
wasn't layering at her i was trying to
make out what i was looking at not for
nothing she was [__] staring at me
all right speaking of which i'm not
gonna say who this was
all right
because it's this person's story um
all right how do i do this
we were hanging out
we went to a a cigar bar in detroit
had a great time met some great people
and uh they were saying now the cigar
bar was was actually on a a suspension
bridge
the owner came over and he was talking
all about it and i guess he
helped design the place and everything
so we're listening and all of that [__]
and uh
there was this other guy over there
and yeah and like
i'm just gonna tell the story he had
this [__] chick with him and she was
just like attending to his every need
right and he was sitting there you know
one of those portly guys you could tell
was gonna get the gout you know
he wasn't a heart attack guy he was a
gout guy you know rich food drinking the
wine and [__] his toes were gonna be on
fire
you know before he hits 35 right so this
woman is just sort of
hanging with on him and i'm thinking
like
wow that's amazing he's got like an
old-school
chick there like she's just like the
level of attention that she's given this
guy i mean it's [__] ridiculous you
know rubbing his shoulders and stuff i'm
like wow
yeah you never see that right
so
then she kind of left
and like didn't come back and everything
and i was like wait a minute does she
like work here is that like a [__]
option or something like i couldn't i
could not figure out what was going on
so anyway we're [__] hanging out
there whatever guys are having some
drinks and [__] i don't drink anymore
long story short
somebody maybe has a couple two three
too many
we all go back to the hotel
and said person is uh you know goes to
sleep they're [__] butt ass naked
they wake up they gotta take a piss
right
so that's dark they don't see too good
they're feeling around for the [__]
door and they finally find the bathroom
door they open the door
and they shut it behind him and then
they've quickly realized they're not in
the bathroom
he was out in the hallway
[Laughter]
[__] butt-ass naked out in the
hallway or the hotel like some wacky
sketch but it was real
so i was like dude what did you do he
goes what can i do he goes i just
covered my junk with my hands and i just
started walking down to the [__]
front desk [__] butt ass naked he
goes down there and it was like three in
the morning so he's thinking well maybe
it'd just be the person who works the
front desk and god will and it's a guy
and i'll be all right he goes down there
there's like 10 people there and he
comes walking around the corner he's
like oh hey whoa what the [__]
freaking out
and he's so chilly he's just like i
thought i was in the bathroom i just
need like a key and everybody just
starts laughing
they give him a key they start escorting
him back up and some woman slapped him
on the ass
[Laughter]
this is my favorite part
he wasn't even embarrassed
like the next day he was just walking
around talking hey how you doing what's
going on like i would be mortified i
would just be like i have to check out
of here because i'm naked guy i got to
get the he just completely didn't give a
[__] nobody cared
and it was uh i don't know it's all how
you carry yourself
um
but jesus christ
[__] crying laughing uh and i love
that the woman slapped him on his ass
when he left too and we were all
laughing through going do you imagine if
it was the other way around if you did
that but i mean obviously you know
there's a physical strength difference i
get it i get it's a different thing but
it was [__] hilarious so um
anyway then we just did uh three shows
at the fox
you know uh i always think chris cornell
when i'm there
uh it's the last place he performed uh
unfortunately and uh so you definitely
feel like one am i
doing here i don't deserve to be here
and you hear that sound and the people
the [__]
detroit comedy fans are [__]
unbelievable i'm just gonna say that
and that that place was incredible and
it's it just shot to the uh
top of the list of my favorite places to
play i've been there before but i don't
know i don't know where my act was at
and then also you know it takes a
certain type of you know
adjustment to play a place like that
and to feel like you should be there so
this time i came out there and i just
you know i'd done it before
you know i didn't feel like uh
how i was feeling before like jesus
christ
i think i probably looked up the people
that had played there and i got a little
shook or whatever
but anyway this time it went great so
then we uh we fly over to uh milwaukee
and i'm going i'm you know meeting all
my buddies you know my knucklehead
friends from high school and [__] and
i'm just like
you know cause we're gonna go to the uh
they're gonna come out to the show
and then we're gonna go up to uh lambo
the next day to go to the green bay uh
[__] uh
seattle seahawk game
right
so
you know and during that time somehow
we're going to take a steam at the
fister hotel my favorite [__] hotel
i know it's a it's an unfortunate name
but it's the fister family p-f-i-s-t-e-r
and it's got the sick of steam and right
as we were pulling up i was like oh [__]
should i book we're getting here on a
saturday [__] because i've never had to
book a steam there of course we get
there and they're all booked up and i
didn't get a chance to get a steam so i
was bummed out by that i was here with
nate craig who's a wisconsin guy you
know i love milkshakes he goes i'm going
to get you a custard he would even call
it a shake he goes we got up here it's
called the custard and get you one
didn't have time we had to do two shows
don't worry we'll get it tomorrow in the
way of lambo all right didn't get we
never [__] got him
then i know this place to get great
brats we didn't have time didn't get him
it just it was just not enough [__]
time but what we did do is go to the uli
cigar shop
um
like we did last time and they let us
come in there and hang out i bought some
cigars and
i got to catch up you know with some
family members and some high school
buddies of mine and we just laughed our
asses off
and uh
and then we [__] go up the next you
know we went out we did two shows
the crowds were great
uh
had one knucklehead both shows
you know there was some woman in the
front row i mean she just was not
laughing
and i was like all right well you know i
am saying the [__] i'm saying so i get
it right
and she was just sitting there just
staring at me like so glumly
this look of pain on her face and i'm
just thinking like why doesn't she just
leave
right
i just don't understand
you know what i mean
white women for some reason when they
don't like something they won't leave
they can't just be like okay this is not
for me
they it they the everything has to
change
everybody around them is enjoying it but
they're not enjoying it so the whole
thing has to stop like i sort of saw a
glimpse of something that happened at
some comic
was some white woman came up on the
[__] stage and was just standing
there
and and as usual the absolutely horrific
security at a [__] comedy club
um
so anyway
i'm getting into my final [__] 10
minutes she's in the front row and she
has her head in her hands
looking down at the floor and at that
point i'm like did she take some edibles
like i don't know what the [__] is going
on here but like i
am seasoned enough now that i never even
[__] addressed it and i was just like
well everybody else is having a good
time and she has free will to get up and
[__] walk out of here so i you know
had a great time and right as i was
getting to the closer she she got up and
the guy she was with got up and they
walked out which was [__] hilarious
to me because it's like you literally
had
90 minutes
well i mean i wasn't on for that one i
was on for like an hour 10 hour and 15
but you had well over a [__] hour
to just stand up and leave
um i don't know maybe she was sick
she looked like she [__]
you know just lost a playoff series in
the end like the level of drama
was uh
i'm not gonna lie to you it was a little
disturbing
so
to the point like i'm doing my [__] and
i'm thinking of my head like did she
just get a text that something's going
on bad at home or something
you know
did she just get dragged to the show and
so anyway
but the rest of the crowd everybody had
a great time and that was it and then i
[__] uh
the next show
i do
crowd's even [__] better
and you know my friends already saw me
on the first show so i was winging it
[__] around so it really freed me up
and i had an even better set on the
second show i was [__] having a great
time and then i just had the commenter
down front
trying to guess where i was going and
blah blah blah blah just so wanted to be
a part of the show so i ignore this guy
i ignore this guy and i'm catching i
caught a zone and i'm just the set is
it's flying
just flying clear skies everything's
great
30 years of experience no one else can
hear the guy don't say anything and then
i'm doing this corporate guy what i'm
saying you know when you have great
sound you can bring your voice down and
sail as crazy [__] and i'm in the middle
of that stuff and this guy's trying to
guess the punchline and i just i don't
know the old me came up i just snapped
i was like will you shut the [__] up
will you shut the [__] and he stands up
oh oh couldn't wait to stand up
couldn't wait to stand up i go stop
acting like you don't know what you're
doing shut the [__] up and he was trying
to talk i just was going shut the [__]
up sit down and shut the [__] up you've
been talking the whole [__] show just
a complete 100 attention [__]
so then i [__] up all the momentum i
had
you know probably [__] up the end of
the show a little bit
and then the self-involved douche i
almost started laughing he was sitting
there with like this hurt look on his
face um
you know it's just like dude if you're
that much of an attention [__] do what
i do go down to a [__] open mic write
five minutes a joke but shut the f oh i
forgot another guy when i was in detroit
i was towards the end of my act this guy
just goes hey bill bell
bell bell bell if i go what
he goes it's always been a dream of mine
to hug you
or something like that it's just like
all right well
unfortunately sir i don't share your
dream right and i just [__] i don't
know what the hell happened with that
guy
i think some people you know they know
where i'm from and then they watch
goodwill hunting too many times and then
they think that they're just gonna
[__] start saying you know it's not
your fault it's not your fault and i'm
gonna collapse and cry in their arms i
don't know what the [__] it was really
weird there was like one weirdo
i did five shows
and i had three weirdos but everybody
else was unbelievable and i want to
thank
everyone in detroit and milwaukee that
came out um
just
you know good lord i mean just as far as
back-to-back cities to do for comedy
that's a that's about as good as it gets
man i was i had i could not have had a
better time
so then along comes uh
sunday
you know and we got seattle versus the
[__] seahawks and on the way up we
got the patriots game on and by the way
is it me or are the new england patriots
the six and four team no one wants to
play
isn't that what they always say
bill belichick in november
i don't give a [__] other than the team
he had like last year
which we would just you know
all of a sudden tom brady's gone we're
trying to get used to cam newton you
know who i liked but you know he had
nobody to throw to
um i heard today they were using them
like a [__] wildcat offense or
something like that it's like can you
give this guy a break he's [__] 35 or
whatever
it gets somebody to throw the [__]
ball to
so anyway um we were watching the game
and they just [__]
destroyed
absolutely destroyed and outclassed
you know one of those things where like
the coach i better the other team was
just like uh you know
can't make any exclus excuses you know
we we got beat on both sides of the ball
you know they came out there uh they
were ready to play and we weren't so you
know hats off to them
and i'm not gonna stand here and make
any excuses and uh
but you know we're gonna put this one
behind us
you know we're gonna have a good week of
practice and we're gonna go out there
and uh
get after it next week because uh that's
all we know how to do around here
coach so and so are you gonna have to
put your house up for sale
um
anyway
so we go to lambeau field
like the holy grail
of uh
you know football stadiums
this is the only one left
i would say soldier field too but like
soldier field is like you know like when
uh uh one of those real housewives goes
out and just gets too much plastic
surgery just gets like frozen face like
if frozen face
was a football stadium
i mean they had one of the
baddest
no [__] around stadiums soldier field
with those [__] columns and just i
mean it was just it was something to
behold and i actually got to go to a
game there before they changed it and
then
the poor people of chicago always said
it looked like they landed a spaceship
on top of the [__] place because they
just built something on top of it it
just
it was uh yeah it was just a complete
clash
you know reminding me as i was driving
out of detroit some landlord built the
biggest [__] bootleg
two family i ever saw it was one of
those great old houses in detroit
that had a big porch around the front
like a wrap-around porch and this guy
built an enclosed staircase
that went up the side of the porch right
along the front of the house and entered
the middle of the front of the house
you know and he put gutters on it too
you know
it was like up to code
it was the ugliest thing
i ever saw and i it uh
and i was trying to think when they
entered upstairs did they enter through
a walk-in closet or was it like a shared
bathroom you know like those in those
old houses they have like the double
entry like the old brady bunch house
which was a mid-century this was an
older house than that
um
so anyway
we're going up to uh
lambeau field and this is my third
attempt
to see a game there i did see a
preseason game with brett favre
a long time ago where he played the
browns and uh i don't know what it was
like
he played like half the first quarter
and that was it
and uh i was playing the skyline cafe in
appleton wisconsin i went over to that
game i think all right maybe i did was
doing some college gigs up there
so then
the next time i went up there i had
tickets for either the sunday night game
and it was me bartnick and verzi we were
all [__] psyched to go to the game
and at that time i was in the middle of
you know we got the tickets and then i
booked an acting gig and i was in the
middle of shooting this thing so they
let me do the gig
but then right after the gig i had to
fly right back
so
i had to say goodbye to them knowing
they were going to lambo because i had
to shoot
you know i had an early call monday in
atlanta so i had to fly and i missed
that game so i'm finally getting up
there
all right
you know [__] green bay versus
seattle
and uh i'm all [__] excited for the
game and everything i can't believe i'm
going in and it's snowing there's snow
flurries on the way up and i'm playing
like the music from [__]
nfl films
[Laughter]
we're all laughing talking about growing
up watching nfl films just having a
[__] great time
so we get in there
we got the perfect seats we're on like
the 45 yard line right at the the last
row of the original stadium because that
was big to me i wanted to sit
um
you know in the original stadium
and by the way the way they added on it
looks [__] great the stadium is
amazing and the fans were awesome
everybody up there was super polite
and it's just it's just and it was just
like going to the movies you know you're
like i can't wait to see this movie
there's nobody loud sitting next to me
and all of a sudden this [__] seattle
seahawks fan comes in
okay
and it was just like
you know couldn't hold his alcohol
and he was just coming he's like uh [__]
the packers
he's just sort of giving the finger to
nobody like both hands
like throwing punches with the finger
you know oh like i'm the crazy guy
and everybody's just sort of looking at
him and then they were introducing the
uh
you know the packers you know number you
know [__] 12 aaron rodgers aaron
rodgers [__] you
suck a dick suck a dick suck it like
doing that there's like kids around and
stuff just being a complete ass
and i'm like
oh this guy's not gonna last
yeah i'm looking around
and people in green bay they're decent
people they're polite people they're not
doing anything but every all of a sudden
you know you start seeing the wrestlers
the football players that people are not
to be [__] with start like turning
around looking at this guy
and me and nate are just laughing going
like this isn't going to end well
and he's like [__] hitting people on
top of their little [__]
pom-poms
going i don't like you i don't like you
[__] you oh [__] he's just an idiot
so finally you know i'm like
you know he starts saying [__] to me and
i'm just like dude
i've been trying to go to this
for [__] ever i have the perfect
seats and i got to sit next to this guy
and i did something
that i've never done before rather than
confront it i was just like you know
what i'm just gonna get away from this
guy we got six tickets and i just asked
my buddies you guys mind if i sit down
there because my buddies they have a
better temperament than i do and they're
like yeah no problem right so i get down
the other side and my biggest buddy
all right big [__] irish dude he goes
that guy's being a problem down there i
go you know he's harmless i go believe
me one of these [__] locals is gonna
handle him and he goes all right and you
know i'm watching the game and all of a
sudden like i don't see my buddy and i
looked down and he and he had gone all
the way down and sat where i sat and
just started looking at him
[Music]
and the guy goes why are you here
and my buddy looks at him
he goes why do you think i'm here
the guy completely imploded and moved
two people over
and um
and that was kind of it and then
fortunately i actually bets uh the
seahawks because you know me and virzie
are going head to head
and uh
i didn't realize you know you could tell
russell wilson's figure was not healed
because there was some throws that he
made that you know
i don't see him make so uh i didn't
understand that and um aaron rodgers
looked great they both had two bad pics
in the end zone but other than that it
was a great defensive [__] game it
was fun watching that guy get shut down
he ended up touching the hat of some
[__]
you know
packer fan
and
what the [__] did the guy say he talked
to him like a child
and this kid could just tell he really
was just like this passive aggressive
[__] [__] who wasn't gonna do
anything and then everybody kind of
realized that and then the packers like
totally shut them out and just shut the
guy down
um
but i was really amazed with the
patience and the friendliness of the uh
packer fans just completely outclassed
this guy i don't think all seattle fans
are like this but like this guy is
unfortunately
one of those guys that exists in every
fan base and it was just like
he was kind of fascinating it was just
like you're in lambeau field
this is like where nfl football began
you're basically in the yankee stadium
of the nfl the most titles
have been won here nfl titles most
titles nfl titles were won here
vince lombardi bart starr
all of those guys nitsky all of those
greninsky all of these guys played
max mcgee
you know
all of these guys [__] played here
and you're not even taking it in
he was acting like he was just at some
[__] espn zone i was really like
you know
i don't know it was really [__]
bizarre
he did come by and hit me on the head he
did that little thing and he hit me as
he walked by and i kind of you know
i don't know i just [__] pushed him
stupid [__] 53 years old pushing
somebody felt good though
[Music]
did feel good
i've been going to the gym you know i
can push a drunk if i want to right so
other than that it was amazing they had
a flyover it was [__] snowing it was
a great game great defensive game which
made sense you know the frozen tundra
and all that [__] and then this old guy
i don't know who he was looked like
chuck yeager saying god bless america
uh at some point i think it was like
halftime
and uh
he absolutely crushed it and um
oh that was another thing that seattle
guy was doing like the national anthem
was going on and he was riffing his own
lyrics
sort of singing patriotic lyrics while
saying green bay could eat a dick and i
was just like
[Music]
this is a support the troops area buddy
you come from a city that big claim to
fame is is
you know starbucks
starbucks was started here and after we
throw we catch the fish we throw it to
each other you know what i mean it's not
exactly known for uh
fisticuffs
what do they do they have new world
order [__] riots or some [__] i don't
want any [__] problem with seattle
i'm not gonna take down the whole
[__] city because of this [__]
jerk off
but um
my buddy actually was telling me this
theory that how they came up with the
12th man
was because they were [__] their fans
over so bad when fans realized that a
large beer and a small beer or whatever
you know they had one tall skinny cup
and one big fat one and someone finally
emptied the short fat one and poured the
big one in it was
the same amount of beer and they were
completely [__] over their own fan
base and i guess all
the original lunatic fans from the
kingdom said [__] this and they weren't
coming around so they had to [__]
kiss their ass and create the 12th man
um and they bought into it
they bought into it uh they also won a
[__] super bowl so i think it worked
out for everybody that's a weird way to
get there
you know
who the [__] made that move hey let's
[__] over our own fan base
um all right so that's it so uh i had a
great time
you know that's how great wisconsin is i
didn't get a milkshake i didn't get a
brat i had one at the game that stunk
but that's what you get when you buy one
at the game and i didn't get to take a
steam here at the hotel but i still had
a [__] awesome time and um
great shows and it was just sort of a
weird
weird thing you know
three weirdos at shows and then the one
[__] weirdo
at the uh
at the [__] packer game but it was
fun watching everybody just sort of shut
the guy down
um but i did see a bunch of other
seattle fans there that weren't acting
like [__] i saw one other guy acting
that way but that you know
it is how it is okay let's uh let's read
some um
some advertising here for the week uh
all right what do we got here
oh look who it is everybody it's ole zip
ray crudo
uh do you know that there are over 10
million job openings
but only 7.6 million unemployed job
seekers yeah what is going on with that
this is weird we're coming out of a
pandemic you'd think that there'd be way
more people needing jobs but i don't
know i don't understand it but this is
the deal and zip recruit is the place to
go and this issue is being worsened due
to a mismatch of employers
and qualified talent so employers are
having to go above and beyond to entice
people to want to work for them if you
can relate to any of these challenges of
growl growing your team then you need
ziprecruiter and right now you can try
zip
code dot com slash bird zip recruiter
uses a powerful technology to find and
match the right candidates
up with your job then it proactively
presents these candidates to you
you can easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply for your job which encourages
them to apply faster no wonder
ziprecruiter is the number one rated
hiring site in the us based on g2
ratings zip recruiters technology is so
affected that four to five employees who
post unzip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day and now
you can try zip recruiter for free at
this exclusive web address zip
crew dot com slash bird that's
zippercrew.com
uh slash burr b-u-r-r zip recruiter the
smartest way to hire
all right sorry i'm blowing through this
i got a [__]
early flight tomorrow
um
all right what do we got here butcher
box everybody butcher box you know when
it comes to meat
uh that will be the centerpiece of your
holiday meals quality matters and when
you invest in high quality meat for
butcher box the benefits go way beyond a
great tasting meal butcher box sources
their meat from partners with the
highest standards for quality no more
searching the grocery store for 100
grass-fed beef free-range organic
chicken wild caught atlantic uh
wild-caught salmon and more
uh their source their sourcing decisions
are made holistically keeping the farmer
the planet the animal and your family in
mind i love having quality food options
in the freezer every month butcher box
ships a curated selection of high
quality meat right to your home free
shipping
uh for the continental united states no
antibiotics or hormones each box
contains between 8 to 14 pounds of meat
ladies depending on your box you ch on
the box you choose that's enough for 24
individual meals customize your own box
or go with one of theirs either way you
get exactly what you want butcher boxes
now
is now off is offering new members sorry
off and free bacon in your first box the
offer this offer is ending on november
21st so get the deal before it's gone
sign up at
butcherbox.com that's butcherbox.com
to get free bacon and twenty dollars off
your first box
all right
let's read some questions here
and then uh
we gotta wrap it up here right
mandalorian pinball machine
hi bill
hello from australia hope you are well
we'd love to see you tour here at some
point in the near future
uh i would love to do it um i got my
mandalorian pinball machine great game
really enjoying it you got one of those
things
those things seem really [__] cool
i just don't have any i got the kids i
have no room for it uh it's awesome to
hear your call outs in the game
i didn't know that happened puts a huge
smile on my face every time hopefully
stern the maker will send you one if
they haven't already they have not and
i'm not asking them to i have no room
for it all right and uh i enjoy pinball
but i don't need one in my house i don't
play it to that level
if i see one
i'll go play pinball but i'm not like a
uh
a pinballer
um
but you know it takes up a lot of space
right
all right
hey [__] hater oh jesus
this might be from the ladies
um oh jesus i went oh and four in my
picks this week after going 4-0 hey
carrot no top i cannot believe your
response to the lady whose boyfriend had
a cat that meows loudly at night
i can't remember what i said uh you
immediately put the blame on the dude
and told her [__] him and his cat he's a
piece of [__] dump his ass well yeah
they had been together for three months
and every night the cat meows so loudly
this person can't sleep
all right i'm paraphrasing but that was
the gist of it usually even when you
have a hot-headed reaction to something
you are able to stop yourself and think
of it from the other side
which is a big reason big part of why i
like your advice portion of the podcast
well thanks for the almost [__]
compliment look at you putting yourself
above me
usually when you have a hot-headed
reaction
um
but here you're a hundred percent on the
girl's side
yeah i'm on 100 on the side of letting
somebody get a good night's sleep
yeah what kind of an [__] gets into a
relationship if they have a cat that
[__] meows all night long so loud
that the person that they're with can't
get any sleep
that'll literally drive somebody insane
anyway do you really not see why the guy
might be hesitant to just get rid of
something he loves so dearly
uh no i just you shouldn't [__] be
living with somebody else
at some point you got look i loved my
pitbull dearly but i knew it would eat
my kids so i gave it away
and i found someone that could [__]
handle the dog which
he did until the dog passed away
i don't understand this i think you just
like you're one of these people that
psycho loves animals
you know maybe that's what it is do you
ever think that maybe you're maybe
you're getting a little hot-headed here
anyway for a lot of people they consider
their pets to be like family
how about that chick get some earmuffs
or earplugs oh [__] you
[Laughter]
there's a lot out there that work great
or you don't feel them when they're in
your ears all right i wear earplugs all
the time because my ears are shot you do
feel them you do feel them in your
[__] ears and i've even gotten those
high-end ones for musicians and they end
up not working after a while all right
i mean i have to go home and listen to
me
[Laughter]
the whole [__] night i have to get
earplugs
i'm not the one screaming and yelling
listen if i was in a relationship and
and the person had a cat and the whole
time the cat was trying to sleep i was
going hey
hey
i can't yell too loud i'm in the hotel i
would expect to be the one that gets you
know i'm the problem i'm going to be
gone
right
anyways let's get back to uh you know
seeing it from the cat's perspective
um some earmuffs
somebody's gonna wear earmuffs earmuffs
do you mean like like
earmuffs like your ears are cold
i don't think that's the problem you
need something that gets rid of sound
um there's a lot out there that work
great and you don't feel them when
they're in your ears that's not true or
maybe shut the door and get a white
noise machine that would drown out the
sound a bit
listen i didn't say to get rid of the
cat
i didn't say that i said get rid of the
guy and the cat goes with him get the
[__] out of here this is it
that is the tip of the [__] iceberg
if somebody's gonna show up with
something that just yells and makes
noise all night
yeah i think maybe that you just you're
into animals and you don't really even
understand human beings how about that
all i know is if a girl said to me
it's me or your dog
i would show her the door 10 times out
of 10. well that's fine and you can keep
your dog and you can jerk off
was she supposed to sit there and deal
with your dog growling at her or
[__] in her slippers and still [__]
you i mean
well you know there's these companies
that make plastic you know booties that
you can put on before you put your feet
in your slippers in case there's dog
[__] in there
uh maybe you're not a cat person or
something but it's a myth that they
don't show affection
they can be every bit as lovable and as
loyal as a dog well i think the fact
that you have to to show that they're
[__] awesome you have to compare them
to dogs says a lot about cats
um yeah i don't have any beef with cats
i don't have any beef with cats if you
have there's a lot of cool cats out
there that just sit in the windowsill
you know they walk around your property
and the road it's [__] you know they
know not to come by there
it's like when you see an american flag
and a trump sign no one's breaking into
that house right same [__] thing
i like cats i don't have any [__]
problem with them i don't want to
[__] live in a hot one where one
won't shut up the whole night
shut the [__] up we're all sleeping
all right
or let the [__] thing out whatever
its problem is
let it go run around and murder some
[__] you know
all right anyway
he said i i l like i said i just
literally can't believe you took her
side so hard buddy you just love cats
you just love cats i get it without even
considering what the guy might be might
think about his girl telling him to get
rid of something he clearly loves a lot
um he doesn't clearly love anything a
lot that's what you deduced from that
because you're you're superimposing
your love of cats and pets and that
they're a part of the family
you're also thinking that i never had a
pet and i don't know what that feels
like
why all the while calling me hot-headed
like i have knee-jerk reactions to [__]
you know for the record but i don't
pre-read these either so you know
there's going to be a lot of shooting
from the hip here
um hope you revisit it at least
have a great day and go [__] yourself
hey buddy
uh i i don't plan on revisiting it
like there was this is some bad moment
in history
it's unbelievably [__] selfish to
have a [__] pet that is keeping the
other person in your life up and to do
absolutely [__] nothing about it
and so you know maybe you could get a
sleep apnea mask and [__] you know
duct tape it around the cat's [__]
face why do i have to put something on
on my girlfriend
all right
[__] cat is living here rent-free it
shits in the house we take care of that
we feed it we rub its [__] belly when
it's in the mood if it isn't it tries to
scratch us
you know instead of just being like hey
i'm you know i'm not into this
however cat would [__] communicate
that i mean i don't know
i don't know you know something i think
you need to revisit it at least because
nowhere in there
did she ever say that this guy loves
this cat more than love itself
all right that was all [__] that you put
in there and you got all butt hurt
because you you love your kitty cat
which i think is fantastic
and i think you should live with your
kitty cat until it dies god willing 17
18 years from now
and uh but i think if that cat is a [__]
and you choose that cat over somebody
else you don't deserve to have them
all right i don't think that's [__] a
hot-headed response
i don't know but you know i don't think
i've reached your level of of you know
enlightenment
all right southern
accents you ever think that maybe just
maybe
maybe that cat saw action over in iraq
and has ptsd how much of a backstory you
gonna build for this [__] cat
all right southern accents
i'm gonna have to listen to people
talking about shelter animals
uh southern accents
hey billy the kid burr on the topic of
southern accents and ignorance i came
across this pretty cool and quick
explanation of where the different
accents
and drawls
nothing else that's just appeared you
mean come from
the women in the video explains how the
american southern speakers are the only
ones left who still sound like our
ancestors
all right is that a good thing you mean
the slave owners
i mean the people who exterminated
indians
she explains that the first and second
generations from great britain spoke in
more of a british accent but the kids of
those parents began to develop an
elongation
in the way they talk well then they they
didn't i mean
we initially came over with the accents
of whatever country we came from
right
the only ones who sound like our
ancestors i i don't know about that
um the women in the woman in the video
then shows the different accents from
the various southern states it's very
interesting and i thought you'd enjoy it
all right i'll check that out and i will
i will tweet out
the link here um
belgian listener
trying to understand cancel culture
oh you owe it to yourself at some point
to go to belgium
oh you got to go there
and how seriously they take beer and
every beer has its proper glass it is
just a [__]
art form
um
man if i ever go off the wagon that's
the place to be
um all right dear bold burr uh big fan
of your work humility energy well talk
to the cat person because they think i'm
a [__] hothead
and uh yadda yadda all right i don't
know
i don't
know you i know you don't read this [__]
anyway all right i'm reading it you know
i'm going to therapy now i'll take a
compliment now
i'm living in belgium come here someday
i i did antwerp one time
brus and i saw tommy aldridge
in the [__]
uh lobby
and i said tommy aldridge
and i knew he was tired from the [__]
road so he turned around like hey and i
just said thanks for all the great music
and i just walked away didn't ask for a
picture no autograph no [__] nothing
but i got to talk to him which was
awesome brussels is full of anglophones
close to the folks you get to meet in
scandinavian countries who all speak
perfect english somehow
um well let's not get crazy they don't
they speak english i can understand
let's not get crazy
i'll come to sweden
uh i must say i struggled to get the
whole cancelled [__] going on in the
u.s
i know we have it here too but as a sort
of watered-down version of what you guys
have once again a great us
first to spread on the world thank you i
know sorry i do get the idea i do get
the snowball process of it well then
there it is yeah it all starts with the
good idea
there's guys taking their dicks out at
work they're [__] raping women and
they have no one to go to and yeah that
unless we should get rid of these guys
and then it becomes a moneymaker
both uh with news organizations and and
these non-profits air quote that [__]
start up and then
you know it's no different than like
when a hurricane happens and a bunch of
people lose everything everybody else
wants to help right so what do they do
they [__] you know they uh
start sending money to these
organizations that pop up and inevitably
you end up finding some of them are
bogus and people just keep the [__]
money and
this
this stuff this cancel culture me too
[__] unfortunately is no different
there's always going to be opportunists
and uh you're starting to see people use
cancel culture
now that they're educated on how the
snowball works to try to just take
somebody out
who didn't even do anything they just
don't like his politics
and it is really [__] amazing to
watch
all of these people that are so-called
progressive sit back and say nothing and
just let it happen because they also
don't like that person's politics
it's pretty sickening
um
anyway i do get the idea says and i get
the snowball process of it yet every
time i try to dig a bit into it seems so
disproportionate that i end up confused
let me explain my confusion
on the recent dave chappelle thing
i see famous americans like joe rogan
like bill maher sort of jumping on the
subject and trying to defend their
fellow comedian
yet whenever i see the actual attack
by which i mean the first outrage take
and not
the even lazier retweeters
oh the retweeters are worse they just
see the accusation and then they just
write and i'm surprised why
you know actions have consequences
you know big surprise
and they don't know they probably
haven't even watched the clip
anyway i see some dude or chick with a
rather low quality media platform
mediocre audience which is what i meant
by disproportionate yeah they're the
ones that get it going i guess i don't
know i i try to ignore all of that [__]
he goes i'm not trying to make you say
the obvious i know right these
untalented wannabe famous douche dick
riding the easy train of lazy outrage to
get some publicity this seems very clear
well you actually just described most of
media
um you know there's just a lot of stuff
to look out there a lot of video games
to play a lot of [__] to stream every
month there's people walking around
going oh my god have you seen squid
games
it's the greatest show ever it's the
greatest show since the greatest show a
month ago and everybody's got to stream
it and get caught up so i think news
agencies um is that what you said news
platforms
people getting in trouble gets clicks
so that's what it is and then when a
person defending themselves
is you know somehow considered going
against the narrative so then they don't
really cover that so they just sort of
become you know
they get used to take people out it's
[__] gross
uh anyway what i don't get is what's the
concrete basis of all this [__] could
you define the stages of cancellation
for me the example you brought with norm
mcdonald on his multiple hilarious snl
bits on oj helped me a lot understanding
his being kicked out of the show and
also made me discover the guy a lot
better thank you so much for this the
guy is now
sitting on the top
on my top comedian list that's awesome
alongside your ginger ass of course uh
there's a big gap between the two of us
but thank you hopefully you're more than
likely real experience with this can
shed a light on the subject and dude
come to brussels don't make me go to
london
these [__] left the union they don't
deserve you also
out of religion and out of therapy uh
good for you now it's time for zen
uh fellow buddhists here won't push
his practice any further than this line
um i could get into that buddhism i
still need a lot of therapy though
you kind of got to work your [__] out i
can't just be like well you know i'm not
going to worry about what i can't
control
dude i can't explain cancel i can't
explain it to you um i can't tell you
that i am a lefty and i am uh
shocked
at what people on the left are doing
to other people with no trials or no
nothing and it has just gone so [__]
beyond
so beyond
you know the initial
you know
legit dirtbags that they were getting
and now now what they do
is they try to just
you know dig up
some sort of [__] something that can
get you canceled they literally go out
and try and find it
to get rid of you because they don't not
not even because they want to stop
whatever their allegedly even happened
if they even [__] happen they just
don't like you
and they're using
you know what i mean
it's just [__] weird they go i hope
somebody got raped so i can get rid of
this person it's like wait wait you
shouldn't be hoping that
the fight like it's just
it's gone kind of bananas and i think uh
i don't think it's a lot of people that
are doing it and i just
i'm hoping you know i feel like there's
a bunch of people in the middle on the
left and the right are just sitting
there waiting for [__] to settle down so
they can poke their heads out again
because everybody's trying to like not
get in trouble
and uh there's got to be a way for the
middle the rational people to be like
hey can everybody just [__] settle
down here
like what do we everybody has a right to
have an opinion everybody can say you
know
you know can chime in just because they
don't agree with you doesn't mean you
now have to [__]
try to end their ability to uh you know
earn a living
i mean does any of that sound crazy it's
[__]
it's [__] bananas
um anyway girlfriend wants to paint my
toenails oh jesus
yeah go go go [__] buy a doll
hey billy one punch i've been with my
girlfriend for about six months now i'm
32 she's 30. she's great we've been
getting along well i've met some of her
friends and we both spent many nights
at each other's apartments i got a
couple of tattoos but she
has a lot of very big ones and plans for
more uh she also has gauged ears i'm
imagine that's when you stick like the
washer in your ear
and a septum piercing
that's the nose deviated septum yeah
okay this is all fine and i find her
very attractive
i'm just trying to get her
personality across most of her
belongings are unique heirlooms or just
out there like decorative animal skulls
or gemstones i just want your opinion on
this thing she keeps bringing up she
wants to paint my toenails
i said no she said why not no one will
see
are you so out of touch with your
feminine side that you can't get your
nails done in a hidden place well that's
an easy answer you just say yes
[Laughter]
or you just say um
are you so up your ass about what you
want to do to me that you can't hear me
saying no
i would just make a joke on it be like
no means no
you know
what you know
[Music]
you got to give it up to women i mean
they are just the best manipulators can
i paint your toenails no i mean no means
no isn't that what they say
why not no one will see are you so out
of touch with your feminine side that
you can't get your nails done in a
hidden place well you know i'm not a
woman
isn't that a good thing do you want me
to have a big feminine side
aren't i supposed to balance you out you
know i mean you want to go to [__]
brunch and go get a you'll get a [__]
bundt cake i don't give a [__]
she goes i like the way she does these
odd sort of things but it makes me feel
weird having it done to me i feel i show
enough femininity towards her in our
texts and snapchats
why do you have to show that towards her
it's because feminists are controlling
controlling the narrative and if you
don't [__] do [__] like this they
automatically think you know that means
you're a toxic male
you know i don't know i think she'll
respect you more if you just stand your
ground and it's just as long as you're
being a good guy you're not calling her
a [__] and you're taking her out to
dinner like i don't think that you
i don't think that you know it's
you know she does you know don't [__]
pay my toenails if you don't mind
um
anyways
does she want me to go through my
routines with this paint
on so she can think about
how i'm being reminded of her what is
she trying to mark me
wait i missed something here i like the
way she does all these odd sort of
things but it makes me feel weird having
it done to me i think you should honor
that you should honor that emotion just
use what they do
you know you're not honoring my feelings
you're not making me feel safe
that's what i would do i would just say
you're not making my toes feel safe
right now i feel i show enough feminine
towards on a text and snapchat is she
trying to mark me
see that's your paranoid they'll do all
of that does she want me to go through
my routines
with this paint on she so she can think
about how i'm being reminded of her
or am i being too defensive about this
whole thing and it's just some fun
um
listen it could be fun if that's what
you want to do but if you don't want to
do it
and then you do this like
i don't know this just seems like this
this new
chatter out there
that this is a balanced relationship
that you as a man
just always do what she wants to do and
that shows that you're a strong man and
that you're in touch with your feminine
side and [__] that
[__] that all right
if you're a good guy and you're treating
her right
okay there's going to be some things
that she wants to do and you're going to
want to do them and then there's going
to be some things that she's going to
want to do and you're not going to want
to do them and that's all right let me
ask you this if you said something to
her can i do this and she said no would
you still be [__] asking
you know maybe she needs to get more in
touch with her masculinity side
anyway um
she he goes it hasn't happened yet but
she's brought it up a few times do i go
go along with it or shut the idea down
for good and see how she takes it thanks
and go [__] yourself uh i don't think
this is about her
this is about you
all right this this
a relationship should not make be made
up
make a break on this and if this is
something you don't want to do then
don't [__] do it
that's it
um
yeah
why does she want to do it
and don't even do that because then
you're back in the conversation and
they'll just [__] wear you down
and then you'll actually have to have
that conversation and you you know one
day when you're in a fight
you know i [__] bring in the trash
barrels
i pay my half for the mortgage i let you
paint my [__] toenails and your
[__] neighbor's head swivel around
um
i don't uh
yeah i i don't think
i think that's a very dangerous way
that men are starting to think i've
noticed with a lot of you younger people
writing in
um
a woman asks you to do something
relationship and you don't want to do it
and then you immediately question
yourself like wait a minute am i being
toxic
am i not being enough in touch with my
feminine side and let me ask you this do
they ask that question
is there any sort of social pressure for
them to ask that question i guess they
have that am i pretty enough
are my tits high enough you know
i don't know but don't they kind of put
that on themselves i don't understand
what the [__] you know
most of us are happy if you just bang us
you know i think that's all it is i i
don't think you should have to go
through the [__]
the clown makeup on your toes if that's
something you want to do but like uh
i i'm a big believer that you know
you you roll with most of the [__]
you know
that they want to do because if you
don't they're going to pout and you have
to d now you got another kid you have to
[__] deal with right so you just go
with that [__] but then there are
certain things you just got to be like
yeah i'm not doing that
why what are you what are you afraid of
i'm not afraid of anything you just
asked me if i wanted to do something i
said no
why is it so difficult for you to hear
me
you just
it's kind of fun you just go right back
at him like that
you know
i don't know sometimes i wish i could
just [__] remember in ghost
when patrick swayze would go into you
know whoopi i wish i could do that with
some of you guys and just [__] have
the conversation i could have it done in
three minutes
i'm not saying when i walked out of you
that they wouldn't be a little pissed
more pissed than they were three minutes
ago but these are really easy [__]
things that handles it a good exercise
and you should go out and go do it so
that's it and ladies if you're listening
if you're asking you got to do some [__]
and he doesn't want to do it well you
[__] lay off every once in a while
you know we're still going to give in to
90 of your [__]
and i think you know can't you live with
that all right it's the holiday season
everybody don't skip over thanksgiving
that's it go [__] yourselves and i'll
check in on you
uh on thursday
you